[Musique]
bienvenue à la ferme de voisins je suis
romain gicquel le chef propriétaire des
lieux et je dormais avec moi pour
montrer comment se passera la
réouverture à partir de 19h congrès le
constater on a déjà commencé à mettre en
place notre terrasse on à la
distanciation absolument partout on a
plus d'un mètre vingt ou un mètre
cinquante ans que chaque table on a créé
un espace qui n'existait pas du tout
donc on avait tout cet espace là qui
étaient du même style
à ma gauche et là on a créé un petit
écrin on va pouvoir vous accueillir cet
esprit un petit peu guinguette dans une
table un petit peu à l'écart mais en
terrasse en même temps un petit peu de
verdure un petit peu de soleil
sympa pour partager un moment avec les
copains on va profiter de cette pause
pour faire un petit peu de travaux
réinvestir sur la terrasse à l'intérieur
également
on a fait quelques modifications des
changements de peinture de moquette etc
[Musique]
je vous montre un petit peu la cuisine
en ce moment on est sur du click and
collect uniquement à partir du 19 mai
nous serons du click and collect plus la
terrasse si le temps le permet et ce
jusqu'au 9 juin à partir de 9 heures
roux le talisman complètement midi et
sera passée entre le 19 mai et 9 20 nous
pourrons accueillir les gens en terrasse
que le mili la cuisine fonctionne déjà
nous allons était bien monté en
puissance au fur et à mesure pour
l'instant on a des équipes réduites on
le sait aussi que quelques heures par
semaine mais il faut savoir aussi que
depuis le début d'année on a essayé de
faire bosser toute l'équipe
un certain nombre d'heures par semaine
afin de remettre tout le monde à 100% de
leur salaire
pour ce qui est de la carte peut donc
profiter de ces instants de cette
période de fermeture entre guillemets
pour un petit peu travaillé nos méthodes
de travail nos modes de cuisson nos
modes de préparation nos modes de
dressage parce qu'il a fallu s'adapter
au click and collect et à la boîte donc
forcément ça impacte également sur la
carte qui va sortir on voit nos grands
classiques tels que la sucette de gambas
la tête de veau le baba au rhum qui font
partie de notre carte de nos plats
signatures qu'on va garder quasiment
l'année tout le temps maintenant et on
aura quelques produits phares tels que
la noix de ris de veau qui est un
produit que j'affectionne
particulièrement qui sera aussi là pour
la rentrée on a des belles zones de
stockage qui sont pour l'instant vide
mais revenez me voir dans quinze jours
et vous verrez qu'on a un petit peu plus
de marchandises
comment prépare-t-on la réouverture au
niveau des stocks
c'est très simple on démarre dès
maintenant on commence à bloquer
certaines marchandises
on se remet en contact à nouveau avec
nos fournisseurs on explique on a
peut-être besoin de ça a besoin de ça et
après on va être comme d'être une autre
métier hyper réactif sur la marchandise
et sur la production et on va s'adapter
au fil de l'eau alors la gestion
économique et financière de
l'établissement est très tendue comme
pour tous les collègues restaurateurs
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on ait un
recours impérieux l'année dernière pour
passer cette période donc autant vous
dire que le pg c'est un prêt garanti par
l'état donc c'est un prêt il va falloir
le rembourser donc on a de l'argent pour
on a débloqué de l'argent pour passer
cette période là mais là c'est pour ça
aussi qu'il faut qu'on redémarre pascal
et une question un petit peu de survie
de l'entreprise et de de re créer un
petit peu de trésorerie pourquoi
seulement payer les fournisseurs pour
que la machine puisse re surveiller
correctement
on est on est très très positif et très
motivé pour la reprise on a vraiment
hâte de revoir les gens ici d'avoir des
clients qui revient de s'attabler dans
notre restaurant on sait qu'il va faire
bosser très dur tout l'été
parce qu'il va falloir faire attention à
l'automne prochain on n'est pas à l'abri
que rebelote
et il va falloir recréer une trésorerie
remettre un petit peu d'argent de côté
pour essayer de pallier à un éventuel
problème en fin d'année
[Musique]